hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions here's a fun
problem I saw online what is the
integral from 0 to 1 of negative 1
raised to the power of X equal to solve
using the principle value pause if you'd
like to give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
well get started with euler's formula
that e to the I theta is equal to the
cosine of theta plus I times the sine of
theta we substitute theta is equal to pi
and then we simplify to get e to the I
pi is equal to negative 1
now we have to be a little bit careful
here because that's not the only way
that we can get negative 1 there are
also other ways that you could get
negative 1 but we'll focus on the
principle value we're now going to raise
both sides to the power of X we can then
use the rules of exponents imply the
right-hand side we're now ready to
evaluate our integral we substitute in
what we just arrived and now we need to
take this integral of e to the power of
I times pi times X this is routine it'll
be e to the I pi X all over I times pi
and we want to evaluate this from 0 to 1
so we substitute those in and now we're
going to simplify e to the I pi is equal
to negative 1 and then we combine these
fractions we could then simplify this a
little bit more we multiplied the
numerator and denominator by I and since
I squared is equal to negative 1 this
all simplifies to be 2i
all over pi so it's pretty interesting
we started out with this fairly routine
integral and we ended up with I and Pi
in the answer amazing thanks for
watching and for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]